Katie is with us in Greenville South
Carolina hi Katie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you Dave I'm happy to talk to you you
too how can I help
so I'm 24 I live with my parents and I
work from home me and my sister really
wanted to move out but we're worried if
we move out well sink deeper into debt
and just be stuck my mom wants us to
stay and pay her off and buy a house
with my dad as a cosigner so I want to
move out in the next couple of weeks but
I'm not sure what to get to stay and
wake my house for right okay
what's your income I make $35,000 a year
but even then I feel like I'm always
living paycheck to paycheck client
where's three thousand dollars a month
going well a lot of taken out for tax so
I about I get about 1200 every two weeks
and I try to pass as much as I can on
credit cards but then I just end up
using the credit cards because I have no
cash and then interesting like $400 a
month going if you live at home credit
cards and I buy food and go out but I
don't think that that's bad I just I
feel like I'm spending so much money and
I'm never paying off my debt yeah what
is that bad because $2,400 a month is
disappearing and you have no idea where
it went
I'm paying off some things so like I
bought a car and I better car like old
cash so I have the $15,000 cash the car
that I bought was all cash but when I
bought it I took all my money and gave
it away so I started using credit cards
at that time and then that piles up and
I've since been seeing also is expensive
now you start using credit cards because
you refuse to live on $2,400 a month
well I took all that cash and a car with
it now 15,000 15,000 is gone and you
bought a car with that but you have
$2,400 a month every month coming in
after taxes and you can't live on that
and you
butthole there's something wrong with
that I can't live on it I just I I'm
fine I know you can't you haven't how
much credit card how much credit card
bill how much credit card there you have
just one okay how much debt do you have
on the credit card okay
all right so here's what you need to do
you need to start telling your money
what to do instead of wondering where it
went
let's go to every dollar and download
the app for your phone and I want you to
build a budget tonight on $2,400 okay
that's what you're bringing home a month
and so $2,400 goes at the top of the
page and we pay the minimum payment on
the credit card what expenses do you
actually have in your budget I pay for
car insurance ninety-two dollars and I
pay my phone and then I pay as much as I
possibly can on credit card stop
something okay you you're still bouncing
all over the place
$2,400 is there at the top of the page
that's a pile of money in the table on
the table okay and we're gonna pay the
car insurance and where do you have to
pay for food at home or only if you go
out no I just I go to the store and just
buy whatever once in a while okay so you
need a food budget right what do you
think you actually spend at the store on
food around sixty a week I think okay
so let's set that at 300 bucks okay
so $300 goes in an envelope right food
on the envelope 2,400 minus 300 is 2,100
then I got to pay $100 in car insurance
that's 2,000 left okay
you see what I'm doing and I want you to
give every dollar an assignment on paper
on purpose and then I want you to stick
to that
because you're just a dog chasing its
tail right now you have no idea where
this is going you're just going in
circles and you have to stop that and
say okay this pile of money I'm gonna be
very deliberate and I'm gonna buy my
food I'm gonna allocate some for going
out but not much you're broke right now
and you're trying to move out but you
can't move out right now you're broke
and you have no idea where your money's
going so for the next 90 days I want you
to tell that $2,400 every month
exactly where to go and then make it do
that make Katie live on Katie's plan
sure I have a car that I bought the car
is worth $15,000 I wanted to sell it and
paid off and kind of live without a car
or as long as I could and then buy a
cheaper one that I could actually afford
and then is that something that I should
be thinking about doing not until you
learn to control your income okay you
don't know where your incomes going
you've got to get control of Katie
because you're gonna burn through 15,000
just like you ran up that credit card
debt and then you're gonna be sitting
there with no car and no money so I
think you're fine to sit on that car the
car is $15,000 and it is paid for
correct
yeah okay we might move down out of it
later in order to come up with a down
payment on a house after you move out by
your $5,000 car have $10,000 in your
pocket start moving towards a house that
kind of a thing that don't be okay but
right now I really want you to get
control of the 2,400 and make it behave
for a little while that's gonna give you
confidence and traction financially and
mathematically so download the every
dollar app and spend the next 90 days
making that $2,400 behave let's pretend
that out of the $2,400 you took half of
it $1,200 and you paid it on your credit
card for three months
your credit card would almost be paid
off and then you'd be a hundred percent
debt-free that sets you up to move out
but most importantly what sets you up to
move out
is you have learned to control Katie you
have learned to control the $2,400
income and making it behave every month
so that's what I would tell you to do
download the every dollar app and start
using it thanks for the call